percent of layoffs for everyone else
compared to how much 343 got was a big
disparity right and then we saw you know
Daystar reporting Lord's giving.net that
we saw that it was a lot of the
narrative team right to me this is where
I'm back with you King is that what this
indicates to me we got to talk corporate
now right when you look at your company
as a whole
you look at what's underperforming in
terms of investment right we can all say
rather how we feel about Halo infinite I
feel it's a great game I actually do
feel it's a great game on its core level
I think it's a great game but we have to
admit it must be internalized as a sales
failure because this is an indictment
you don't go attack this team
specifically unless you feel you didn't
just again you did you didn't feel you
got the return of investment based on
what you put in so that's what it is you
know I want to be clear though again
where I do it I kind of weird on the
green with Kingdom a lot this way but